et
[Musique]
l'egypte ils ont réussi à calmer un peu
gégène en lui jouant de la musique
les shadoks en profite pour aller à
l'école dans le cadre de la campagne
d'éducation des shadoks que nous avions
promis au début de notre feuilleton nous
allons en discuter au premier cours de
logique shadok le professeur jadot coup
au programme les passoires
on appelle parfois tout instrument sur
lequel on peut définir trois
sous-ensembles l'intérieur l'extérieur
et les plus l'intérieur est généralement
placés au dessus de l'extérieur et se
compose le plus souvent de nouilles et
dont les trous ne sont pas importants en
effet une expérience simple permet de se
rendre compte que l'on ne change pas
notablement les qualités de l'instrument
en réduisant de moitié le nombre des
trous puis on réduise en cette moitié de
moitié etc etc et à la limite jusqu'à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus de trous de tous tout
théorème la notion de passoire est
indépendante de la notion de trous et
réciproquement
on n'appelle pas soir du premier ordre
les passoires qui ne laisse passer ni
les nouilles ni l'eau on n'appelle pas
soir du second tour dhr les passoires
qui laisse passer et les nouilles et
l'eau on n'appelle pas soir du troisième
ordre ou passoire complexe les passoires
qui l'espace est quelquefois le new
l'ombre et quelquefois pas pour qu'une
passoire complexe laisse passer l'eau et
pas les nouilles
il faut et il suffit que le diamètre des
trous soit notablement inférieur au
diamètre des nouilles pour qu'une
passemar complexe laisse passer les
nouilles et pas long il faut il suffit
que le diamètre des trous soit
notablement inférieur au diamètre de
l'eau quant aux passoire du premier rang
qui ne laisse passer ni les nouilles ni
l'eau il y en a 2 200 les passoires qui
ne laisse passer ni les nouilles ni
l'eau ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre et
celle qui ne laisse passer ni les
nouilles ni longs que dans un sens
seulement c'est pas soir là on les
appelle des casseroles il y a trois
sortes de casseroles les casseroles avec
la queue à droite les casseroles avec la
queue à gauche
et les casseroles avec pas de queue du
tout mais celle là on les appelle des
autobus
il est à trois sortes d'autobus les
autobus qui marchent à droite les
autobus qui marchent à gauche et les
autobus qui ne marche ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre
mais ceux là on les appelle des
casseroles il y a trois sortes de
casseroles les casseroles avec la cure à
trotte les casseroles radical
[Musique]